décidément ce sont les faits divers et
leurs conséquences qui ont la vedette
aujourd'hui ce matin a commencé à
marseille le procès de charles ranucci
accusé d'avoir enlevé une petite fille
au mois de juin 1974 une petite fille
qui a été retrouvée assassinée de quinze
coups de couteau sur l'un des portiques
de pierres blanches de la façade du
palais de justice d'aix
il y a marqué en grosse fête bleue oui à
la peine de mort est dans la salle
d'assises une foule ta c est pour
l'instant silencieux semble contenir ses
cris de haine dans ces conditions c'est
l'honneur du barreau que le défendre une
cause
ça veut dire une tête qui paraît perdue
d'autant que christian ranucci agressif
arrogante et et adopte un système de
défense qui contribue à aiguiser
l'atmosphère en somme il rejette tout il
dit j'ai été torturé par les policiers
alors j'ai avoué tout ce qu'ils ont
voulu
et il ajoute j'étais ivre je ne me
souviens de rien malheureusement les
précisions de ses aveux et l'examen des
experts contredisent ses protestations
d'innocence alors il reste le corps
d'une fillette transpercé de coups de
couteau et un homme dont le geste défie
la raison et c'est là que le procès des
ex prend une autre dimension ranucci
n'est pas fou intelligent d'une bonne
culture pas de drogue pas d'alcool pas
de déviation mental même pas ce fameux x
chromosome supplémentaire dont on dit
que c'est la fatalité du crime
christian ranucci et simplement doté si
l'on peut dire d'une émotivité excessive
d'une sexualité hésitante une
personnalité floue et écrasé par l'image
d'une mère possessive ranucci a tué sans
l'avoir prévu sans l'avoir désiré sans
en avoir besoin
il s'est écrié tout à l'heure en parlant
de l'enfant nos routes se sont croisées
je ne la connaissais pas je n'y peux
rien personne ne l'a cru
dramatique accident